bonsoir bienvenue sûreté des fils pour
le journal de la rédaction nous sommes
le 12 novembre voici les titres de cette
édition du 7 8 l'aktu près de 4300
entreprises sont créées chaque année
dans les yvelines pour mieux se faire
connaître et mieux appréhender l es
demande de ses patrons une rencontre
avec les créateurs et est organisée par
la chambre de commerce
plus de 1000 jeunes en uniforme bleu ont
monté leur tente pour trois jours de jeu
mais aussi de compétition à bonnel
durant le week-end de reportages autour
un grand rassemblement de scouts et puis
dans ce journal nous consacrerons une
large place aux sports anthony rech où
il rejoindra pour faire le point sur les
compétitions du week end est évoquée
avec son invité le prochain raid 100 %
féminin de l'arbre vert
les archives départementales des
yvelines son partenaire de la grande
collecte des documents là de la première
guerre mondiale collecte qui se
terminera dans une semaine l'image du
jour c'est donc à la trappe que nous la
trouvons ce mardi dont les yvelines
mémoire de trappes est un lieu de
référence pour cette collecte tous les
après midis depuis aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au 15 novembre il est possible
d'apporter toutes sortes de documents
cartes postales écrits photos carnets
militaires tout ce qui peut retracer la
vie des combattants et démobilisés de la
grande guerre leur histoire est ensuite
retracé et elle pourra servir à
alimenter une bibliothèque numérique
européenne en ligne
il faut retracer l'histoire de l'un
d'eux de lier en question qui essaie
d'avoir un maximum d'informations de
photos de des visuels aidant aussi les
courriers mais ça peut être des diplômes
ça peut être des courriers donc de la
personne
du combattant ça peut être des alors des
documents officiels comme l'acte de
décès ou des choses comme ça qui va vous
permettre de retracer la vie sont sur le
front depuis 14 à 18 du combattant on
numérise
et dans un premier temps donc soit on
demande aux gens de revenir pour les
récupérer quand ils n'habitent pas trop
loin en tout cas chaque personne ne
repart avec ses objets ici bien à des
documents qui pourront aussi servir aux
archives départementales pour constituer
les ouvrages des combattants de la
grande guerre dans les yvelines pas de
champ de bataille certes mais des
soldats partis au front à trappes
notamment 53 combattants ont péri et
puis rester avec nous parlons bien sûr
de la commémoration 14 18 dans quelques
minutes en attendant économie près de
4300 entreprises sont créées chaque
année rien que dans le département des
yvelines pour mieux connaître et mieux
appréhender les demandes de ses nouveaux
patrons une rencontre avec elle les
créateurs et est organisée par la
chambre de commerce les questions sont
nombreuses alors qu'une enquête
médiamétrie révèle que les sociétés
chinoises souffrent durablement de la
crise quatre réseaux lato elodie moines
le point commun entre tous ces chefs
d'entreprise ils sont nouveaux dans les
yvelines pour la première fois la
chambre de commerce leur a proposé une
rencontre afin de leur présenter des
outils mis à leur disposition
les questions ne manquent pas les
questions c'est par rapport aux normes
des personnes à mobilité réduite pour
les changements également pour les aides
qu'on puisse avoir quelques problèmes
latents qui sont plus le niveau des
impôts les choses comme ça que je
regarde que je vais toujours kambale en
2012 plus de 4300 entreprises ont été
créées en majorité dans le domaine des
services une récente enquête médiamétrie
pointe du doigt des inquiétudes parmi
les chefs d'entreprise les responsables
de pme font état d'une sensible
dégradation de leur activité dans le
département des yvelines d'après les
enquêtes qui ont été fait c'est surtout
effectivement le commerce et le commerce
non alimentaire en particulier qui
s'ouvre mais aussi les autres
entreprises qui ont pas prévu ni
d'investir ni de recruter et je pense qu
on est dans une période un petit peu
compliqué actuellement il y en a besoin
justement d'accompagner les entreprises
on est là pour apporter peut-être des
solutions kuhn auquel il ne pense pas
des nouveaux outils dead qui passe par
un rapprochement géographique les
yvelines sont maintenant découpé en cinq
zones et un élu et un conseiller sont
affectés à chaque partie du territoire
mais ce n'est pas tout nous
réfléchissons beaucoup sur un certain
nombre de caution
on essaie de trouver des idées sur les
plans de revitalisation
on espère pouvoir trouver des solutions
sur les prêts
aux entreprises qui ont besoin d'emprunt
on a plusieurs pistes actuellement
minutes un petit peu tôt pour en parler
des soutiens qui sont un véritable enjeu
car comme l'affirment girard bacheliers
lui-même chef d'entreprise le plus
difficile n'est pas de créer sa société
mais de la faire évoluer une prochaine
soirée bienvenue en yvelines sera
organisé en février 2014
ce week end les scouts d'europe du
département se sont réunis à bonnel plus
de 1000 jeunes en uniforme bleu qui sont
venus monter leur tente pour trois jours
de jeu mais aussi de compétition des
jeunes de 12 à 18 ans et qui tentait de
se qualifier pour l'euro jam c'est un
rassemblement mondial cette fois ci des
scouts d'europe ça se déroule tous les
dix ans les précisions clair qu'en
billets patrick jacques de dixmude
un impressionnant campement a investi
les plaines de bonnel ce week end 1200
scouts d'europe venus de tout le
département trois jours de gadoue de
rencontres et d'activités en tous genres
car des biens dans l'ombre
nous retrouvons la troupe
saint-quentinoise à l'atelier secourisme
certains sont interrogés pendant que
d'autres doivent construire un brancard
on fera ça aussi ça m'avait agressé à
transporter on prend de vouloir ont fait
passer des montants l'intérieur d'un
camion les ceinturons pour
cette rencontre annuelle est un peu
synonyme de compétition cette année les
40 unités temps de se qualifier pour
l'euro jam un événement réunissant tous
les scouts d'europe douze mille jeunes
issus de 15 pays ils se retrouveront en
lorraine l'été prochain
rien qu'en france on compte trente mille
adhérents autant dire que les places
sont chères c'est un grand événement qui
n'arrive que tous les dix ans donc il
faut essayer de sélectionner avec cette
épreuve ont-ils une chance de se
qualifier
savent ils sont pas trop mal y'a pire il
ya pire
prochaine étape l'atelier des noeuds la
troupe compte sur sa complémentarité
moi personnellement c'est parce qu'en
membres en forme et j'ai des scouts il
sera séduit là dedans donc je pense que
ça va aller françois est le chef de
patrouille une hiérarchie spécifique à
ce mouvement catholique jusque dans le
monde à un système qui est bien à nous
et qui nous distingue vraiment des
autres ce qu'on fonctionne en patrouille
hier quand on va confier un groupe de
six personnes à un jeune de 17 18 ans
qui en a la charge et chaque patrouille
à sa tante et donc ils sont tous arrivés
là il ya cent quarante et une patrouille
pour les yvelines ils sont tous arrivés
ils ont tous mis leurs tentes à
l'atelier ne pierre-marie se positionne
comme le spécialiste
les épreuves vont s'enchaîner tout au
long de la journée ce soir place à la
fête une grande veillée se tiendra dans
cet amphithéâtre naturel
irl en cours ont commémoré comme dans la
plupart des communes françaises le 11
novembre
1918 le coup d'envoi du centenaire de la
grande guerre lancée par le président
françois hollande la semaine dernière
anciens et jeunes se sont donc retrouvés
et les enfants ont lu des lettres de
poilus et olivier maniscalco patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images
un devoir de transmission de mémoire
pour la commémoration du 11 novembre
1918 la ville d'elancourt avait réuni
ses anciens ces jeunes sur le parvis de
la ferme du mousseau de classe de cm2 de
l'école de villedieu étaient présentes
l'occasion de rendre hommage générations
confondues aux soldats morts pour la
france l'occasion également pour les
petits de lire en public des
correspondances de poilus aujourd'hui
tous disparu des lettres qui rappelle à
tout le monde l'atrocité de la guerre et
laisse imaginer aux enfants ce que leurs
ancêtres ont enduré
mareuil de tués est poussé par l'odeur
de la poudre aussi bien que par les cris
de bête féroce car à ce moment là on
devient des bêtes féroces rosso qu'à
tuer et massacrer nous nous élançons
tout comme un seul homme
c'était très difficile
et il devait d'en souffrir il devait
avoir peur il devait penser à leurs
familles
ça devait pas être très drôle pour eux
c'est bien toi tu ouvres tiennent leur
image
ce qu'ils ont fait très très très vite
et très très courageux il est
fondamental de se souvenir de ce qu'ils
ont fait
car si nous avons la liberté doux de
nous exprimer actuellement est de
vouloir faire un peu ce que l'on veut
restons dans des limites correct quand
même c'est bien grâce à leurs sacrifices
apprenez
pénétrer vous de l'histoire de france
qui est magnifique
pénétrez vous de ce que ces gens là ont
fait et dites-vous comment faire pour
que cela ne recommence pas à montigny le
bretonneux la ville poursuit son action
envers les personnes retraitées avec
l'ouverture d'un relais seniors
aujourd'hui un lieu pour partager à son
déjeuner dans un contexte convivial un
cadre agréable une façon de lutter
contre l'isolément des personnes seules
parfois on manque d'autonomie en leur
offrant un cadre pour renouer
socialement des activités sont aussi
proposées l'après midi elles étaient
plus d'une vingtaine de personnes de
plus de 65 ans pour ce premier jour à
s'inscrire le service fonctionne lundi
mardi jeudi et vendredi le tarif varie
en fonction du niveau de ressources de 4
à 12
et puis cette autre information face à
la terrible catastrophe provoquée par le
typhon sur les philippines et le vietnam
le secours populaire lance un appel à la
générosité populaire les différentes
antennes locales sont mobilisées dont
celle des yvelines pour faire un don
l'adresse s'est affiché sur votre écran
il ya aussi un site internet
www.sncf.com 18 points comme elle la
catastrophe a déjà fait plus de dix
mille morts 2000 disparus aient les
vents ont soufflé à plus de 380 km heure
ravageant 70 à 80% des zones traversées
une fois n'est pas coutume on passe aux
sports bonsoir anthony quinn bienvenue
sur ce plateau oui j'ai vu de la lumière
je suis rentré je vous ai manqué un
petit peu un petit peu il n'y avait pas
d'édition sport hier si vous nous suivez
si vous êtes des fidèles pas de 7,8
sport hier est donc une page spéciale
sport dans cette édition de l'actu oui
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour un set
sports un petit peu exprès ans et numéro
36 quand même une édition express je
lisais c'est parti pour un nouveau tour
de l'actu pop du département mais cette
fois ci en 13 minutes et sans perdre de
temps place à l'édition 2013 du raid de
l'arbre vert la seule compétition de ce
type 100% féminine et parmi les 270
participantes servane gabillon vous êtes
en train de boucler les valises
j'imagine alors qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de repartir sur ce raid pour
la troisième fois déjà l'esprit de
compétition qui est très important dans
ce raid avec un esprit d'entre elles qui
est sympa le fait de découvrir des pays
différents tous les ans cette année
c'est en malaisie et c'est un pays que
je connaissais pas du tout donc ça tombe
bien et puis on est une équipe très
soudée avec laquelle on se rend bien et
on fait des week-ends entraînement
régulier tout au long de l'année c'est
vrai que c'est aussi sympa de
s'entraîner tout ensemble que de
participer au raid on lui même donc
c'est pour faire du tourisme en fait ça
pour faire du tourisme bah en fait ça
permet de découvrir un pays
de manière un petit peu original on nous
ouvre des secteurs qui sont pas du tout
ouvert au tourisme en règle générale on
court dans des coins qui sont fabuleux
des réserves de chasse c'est un petit
peu extrême cours
à bah oui oui non mais on court on fait
du canoë et puis on fait du vtt donc
voilà et tous les jours il ya une
épreuve différente sous forme de soit
mono sport soit du biathlon soit du
triathlon avec des épreuves sportives
surprise au cours du raid je sais pas
c'est parce que c'est votre troisième
passage sur l'épreuve comment vous avez
découvert le raid de l'arbre vert c'est
une amie qui m'avait demandé de
participer avec elle et puis cet ami l'a
n'a jamais pu le faire parce qu'elle
était enceinte et c'est donc en fait
c'est une la deuxième de l'équipe
delphine rendent mal d'air qui étaient
là dedans la troisième coéquipières avec
qui je suis resté et puis donc une 3e
sonia bardaine voilà mais je n'ai
découvert par hasard par cette amie
commune en fait alors si vous nous
suivez en direct ans et pas une épreuve
c'est faire du raid nature
tombés d'accord on attend donc dans le
four votre téléviseur vous n'avez rien à
régler ça vient uniquement de nos
voisins qui s'installe de nouveau
nouveau voisin charles voisin quelques
travaux quelques petits travaux à
boucler visiblement avant la fin de la
journée et qui ont décidé de nous
embêter un petit peu mais c'est pas là
on va relever
la
situation serait donc on va les y alla
de l'arbre vert vous y allez pour la
gagne quand même un petit peu parce que
le côté sportif la gagne peut-être pas
parce qu'on n'est pas on fait pas partie
des équipes qui peuvent prétendre à la
gagne il ya délia trois équipes qui se
détachent toujours vraiment beaucoup
dans le raid nous on est plutôt dans les
dans les quinze équipes premières voilà
donc l'année dernière on a fait 11e
cette année je sais pas si on est aussi
en forme que l'année dernière enfin moi
peut-être un peu moins et voilà comme
l'épreuve la plus difficile sur le raid
de l'arbre vert c'est la course et le
vtt le canoë en fait ça dépend un peu de
chacune moi mon épreuve les preuves que
j'aime le moins c'est le trail l'épreuve
que je préfère c'est le cadeau et mais
après en général c'est plutôt des
coureuses les filles qui font leur aide
voilà c'est plutôt leur épreuve phare
c'est plutôt la course à pied puis le
cadeau et c'est un peu la bête noire des
concurrentes en général alors le rêve de
l'arbre vert et connu wilfried 1 puisque
c'était le seul raid 100 % féminin alors
on a été un petit peu taquin ce soir on
est malade chose et on assume tous les
deux nous allons nous sommes allés poser
la question aux saint quentinois savoir
un petit peu ce qu'il pensait d'un raid
100 % féminin et si les femmes étaient
plus apte à un acte que les hommes à
exécuter ce genre de raid on n'est pas
encore question macho ce soir
c'est absolument pas quelque chose qui
est jean henri par sexe selon la
détermination qu'on y met et voilà ça
change pas absolument j'aime pas
je ne pense pas parce que justement les
différences entre hommes et femmes sont
au niveau physique et les femmes sont
conçus d'une autre manière que les
hommes niveau sport c'est pas forcément
les hommes qui sont supérieurs aux
femmes j'ai pas style et la rente est
donc bon que ce soit niveau sportif ou
tout le reste je suis convaincu que il
ya une année une sorte d'égalité
dépendamment du sport peut-être les
capacités physiques sont pas les mêmes
pour tous donc naturellement il ya
dichotomie entre les deux sexes soient
là je pense mais après tout les genres
enfin les deux joueurs peuvent faire
n'importe quelle histoire on n'est pas
égaux à ma femme mais si on est
confrontés les uns aux autres
effectivement non il ya pas qu est plus
apte que l'autre non pourquoi pourquoi
oui non
pour les raids sportifs
ils ont peut-être un tout petit peu plus
d'entraînement mais les femmes aussi
sont très entraînés à l'heure actuelle
et 413 sportive et
elles sont aussi elles ont aussi
beaucoup d'atouts vous êtes plutôt
d'accord avec les réponses des saint
quentinois c'est normal moi je pense
surtout que c'est l'ambiance qui est
différente dans un raid féminin c'est à
dire que on est à maquillage je suis
désolé
non c'est surtout que c'est facile je
sais lire
j'ai entendu lorsque vous dans cette
oreillette c'est beaucoup plus solidaire
qu'un raid bascule en terre que y'a pas
que la compétition c'est que quand quand
il ya une équipe qui est en galère les
autres vont l'aider et même si c'est une
équipe qui est devant on va pas lui
marcher dessus pour passer que de fortes
alors que c'est vrai que souvent chez
les autres et même sur les raids mx-5
mixte c'est juste ça peut être un peu un
peu plus chaud mais aussi assez bon
enfant quand même vous parler d'ambiance
leur sève de l'arbre vert est réputé
justement pour la cohésion on sort
vraiment grandi de cette expérience là
oui tout à fait parce que ces règles de
de se dépasser
mais on est en équipe c'est un
s'informent pas mal ça crée aussi pas
mal de tensions mais quand on est
content on s'entend bien et qu'on arrive
à bien à bien synchroniser tout va bien
il ya des équipes qui piquent
c'est pas dangereux justement d'y
participer si on est mal préparée en
fait il faut se préparer un minimum il
ya des gens qui se prépare plus ou moins
bien c'est pas forcément tant la
préparation c'est le fait de connaître
de s'écouter c'est de courir ici quand
il fait froid et courir sur 35 degrés
avec 90 de la possibilité c'est pas
pareil et souvent celles qui se font mal
c'est plutôt celles qui sont fortes
parce qu'elles n'ont pas l'habitude de
s'écouter elles ont l'impression
qu'elles peuvent aller aussi vite que
d'habitude où environ aussi peu et mon
petit faut bien savoir ce que coûtait
donc les accidents c'est plutôt celle
d'helmand générale montre qui vont
au-delà d'elle-même camp qui veulent
aller toujours plus loin à quelques
jours du départ le début de l'épreuve
c'est pour le 19 novembre en tout cas le
départ de l'aéroport charles de gaulle
vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit
impatiente il ya de l'excitation qui
règne en un petit peu dans web à la en
fait on revient d'un week-end
d'entraînement à marseille on était
toutes les trois donc on a fait les
calanques moi je suis surtout en train
de récupérer des jambes parce que pour
l'instant j'ai un peu de mal à marcher
sinon oui on prépare les valises les
trousses de médicaments
et savoir ce qui nous manque et plutôt
excité way et puis un peu dans le speed
du boulot parce que on est toutes les
trois indépendante et que quand on n'est
pas là il faut que ça tourne quand même
il ya le côté sportif on en a parlé mais
pour le reste de la revers il ferait il
faut réunir des fonds chaque équipe doit
récolter à peu près onze mille euros
c'est déjà la première épreuve hors
taxes c'est déjà la première épreuve du
raid ont un petit peu en fait ces essais
wes et c'est vraiment un projet sur le
long terme qui dure à peu près vingt six
mois entre l'entraînement la recherche
des fonds etc nous on a la chance parce
que on a un sponsor qui nous suit depuis
le début qui a atterri voilà qui
effectivement des luminaires et puis et
puis en fait ma coéquipière qui habite
en angleterre elle elle se penche au
rize avec sa société ect chine et puis
la marseillaise delphine s'autorise
aussi avec sa société et puis et puis
zéro forfait qu'un opérateur de
téléphonie mobile mais non c'est pas
évident de trouver des fonds surtout
depuis deux ans avec la crise ils n'ont
pas forcément envie de nous donner
beaucoup d'argent
michel soir sur le plateau voilà au
moins ils sont cités en panne depuis
cette semaine c'était très bien mais
c'est pas donc départ le 19 novembre
puis on espère vous voir au retour un
peu après le 28 novembre qu'on vous
serait rentré pour nous raconter tout
cela on n'a pas de problème eh bien vous
couvrir pour cette compétition qui
beaucoup et on poursuit cette page de
sport dans le 7 8 dans le journal de ce
soir pendant trois jours vélizy
accueillait la finale de la coupe du
monde 2010 ed près de 130 pilotes
spécialistes de ces bolides à l'échelle
1 28e se sont affrontés à coups de
chrono nous avons suivi les
qualifications pour les finales autant
dire que c'est l'un des moments les plus
importants de la compétition à première
vue on se croirait dans un paddock de
formule un sur chaque établi autant
d'outils de carrosserie de pièces
détachées que dans les stands d'une
grande écurie ces dizaines de pilotes
sont les meilleurs du monde mais à
l'échelle 1 28e ils sont aux commandes
de mini z pour chaque catégorie les
pilotes bénéficient de plusieurs séances
de qualifications pour effectuer les
derniers réglages nathalie participent à
la finale de la coupe du monde dans deux
classes différentes dont la mythique le
mans c'est son époux qui fait office de
mécanicien ça dépend de la tees de sa
défense à sa droite et sa gauche pas
donc on peut changer des pièces on peut
changer les pneus et réglages qu'après
au bout d'un moment
avec 130 pilotes et 13 nationalités
différentes
l'accès à la piste de la finale mondiale
est strictement réglementée on vérifie
le poids de la voiture complète avec les
accus le moteur si les c'est bien
toujours le même auteur donc il est
numéroté et
individualisé par par pilote et donc on
vérifie les pneus parce que c'est des
pneus bien spécifique pour la piste
voilà le verdict sur le podium commande
à la main pendant une vingtaine de tours
les pilotes entrent dans une
concentration ultime toujours à la
recherche de la trajectoire optimale
mais parfois jusqu'à la rupture et la
sortie de route moi j'ai perdu un d'or
qu'elle à la fin justement
la voiture allait bien oui ça allait
mieux encore quelques fautes un petit
peu problème avec les trafics mêle
aventure
dans cette course au temps nathalie et
steve ne décrocheront pas le temps
scratch près de 200 départs ont été
donnés à vélizy tout le week end le
dimanche la plupart des finales ont été
trustées par les pilotes finlandais
l'essentiel du sport les autres
résultats à retenir de ce long week-end
de trois jours et on va commencer par du
football 8e journée de division
d'honneur versailles recevait le
deuxième créteil lusitanos au stade mont
boron ce dimanche et les joueurs de ses
deux david giguet ont signé la
performance du week-end en s'imposant
très facilement 4 0 avec cette deuxième
victoire de la saison ils remontent à la
7e place en promotion d'honneur pour le
compte de la 6e journée trappe recevait
quincy-voisins au stade gilbert science
ac ce dimanche pas grand chose à se
mettre sous la dent en première période
le match va complètement se débrider
après l'heure de jeu à la 70e minute les
trappistes ouvre le score sur un
dégagement complètement raté du gardien
adverse c'était c'est sami courade un
qui a bien suivi la frappe de souleymane
compte et qui n'a plus qu'à pousser le
ballon dans le but vide vous voyez
d'ailleurs voilà sept reprises après la
frappe sur la barre transversale 1-0
huit minutes plus tard parfaitement
décalé halak à l'entrée de la surface de
réparation jalala saab se joue du
gardien sur ce crochet du droit avant
d'enrouler sa frappe le numéro 10
trappistes restera d'ailleurs un doublé
sur cette énorme faute de main du
gardien de quincy voisins qu'on va voir
juste derrière voilà le gardien qui sort
un peu malencontreusement en tout temps
un match qu ainsi réduira le score pour
la forme trappe s'impose 3-1 et se
reprend après sa défaite la semaine
passée ce qui ravit l'entraîneur saint
quentinois
je pense que physiquement on a réussi à
passer dessus sur l'équipe adverse
n'était plus meilleur une meilleure
présence dans les duels et beaucoup plus
de présence mans physiquement sur mes
joueurs à the russian à jouer jusqu'à la
dernière minute ces parts étaient avant
pour l'instant il n'ya pas d'objets pas
d' objectif bien précis sur leur montée
ou quoi que ce soit on joue les matches
les uns après les autres et on verra ça
suit ce qui se passera dans les autres
rencontres de promotion d'honneur
guyancourt n'a pas réussi à bonifier sa
première victoire de la saison les
joueurs de jus de talent moreau se sont
inclinés sur la pelouse du vin seynois 1
0 et il stagne du coup à la 9e place au
classement il y avait du foot aussi au
niveau départemental ce week-end
deuxième tour de la coupe des yvelines
qu'il n'a pas été très prolifique 1 pour
les clubs saint quentinois pour
l'instant aucun club n'est qualifié
saint cyr et guyancourt sont passés à la
trappe sont passés à la trappe et les
rencontres entre montini le pecs et
entre trappe et est cueilli ont été
reportés ils étaient près de deux cents
ap pour le départ de la première édition
de la course royal ce dimanche matin de
la pièce d'eau des suisses au château de
versailles pour une distance de 20 km
direction fontenay-le-fleury les 10
premiers kilomètres et est très roulant
mais après avoir quitté le château les
coureurs traverser la plaine de
versailles et la forêt avec la pluie de
ces derniers jours le chemin était donc
très glissant au terme des 20 km s'est
levé lisez un jonathan du high qui s'est
imposé en une heure huit et ce quelques
secondes on les écoute je suis parti
avec la tête au départ mais ils sont
partis très vite donc j'ai pas suivi
tout de suite et puis après je suis
revenu il s'en tiraient la bourre à deux
là donc je pense qu'il était un peu
fatigué après je suis revenu par la
suite moi ya quelques petites côtes en
fait il allait falloir dernier quelques
petites côtes boueuse et tout donc je
savais qu'il fallait mettre les
chaussures de trail la fin ça s'est
super bien passé
parcours super jolie je me traîne dans
le coin de souci particulier pour la
corse en tennis de table 4e journée de
championnat par équipes de nationale 2
femmes et l'encours s'est inclinée 8 4
face à fontenay de son côté l'entente de
voisins saint-arnoult s'est imposé dans
la douleur à lescun dans le nord pas de
calais 8 6 avec cette quatrième victoire
en autant de journées les joueuses de
geoffrey nisand sont évidemment leader
de leur poule d de nationale 2 avec 12
points et deux longueurs d'avancé sur
mayenne les saint-quentinoises reste la
seule équipe encore invaincue en
volleyball cinquième journée de
régionale une week-end contrasté pour
les clubs saint quentinois montini est
passé tout près de la victoire à ans et
chevry mais s'incline finalement 3 sets
à 2 de son côté plaisir ville procès
balader sur le terrain dernière victoire
3 sets à 0 des plaisirs war reste leader
montigny 5e en badminton ce week-end
maurepas accueillez la deuxième étape du
challenge départemental jeunes au
gymnase de malmö donne sur deux jours
140 joueurs des catégories poussins à
cadets se sont affrontés le challenge
des jeunes est divisé en trois divisions
1 2 1 pour les meilleurs à 3 pour les
moins bons joueurs maurepas était une
étape de division 3 et le club de
logiciels s'est particulièrement
illustré ce week-end merci anthony pour
ce point sur le sport la semaine
prochaine retour à la normale on vous
retrouvera dès 18h30 lundi pour un 7 8
sport un corps encore plus complet c'est
à dire un peu plus mais encore plus
complet merci anthony c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous retrouve demain en
direct à 18h n'oubliez pas si vous nous
suivez aussi ce soir en direct que je
vous retrouverai pour un nouveau numéro
de municipal 2000 14e reçoit michel
besson candidat ps à elancourt et
nicolas danville candidat divers droite
à la verrière bonne soirée
use